hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're going
to be going over a nice little chess
tactic called the windmill and basically
you're going to be using a lot of
discovered checks and regular checks to
completely dominate your opponent and
pretty much gobble up all his pieces on
the board that you can so today we're
going to look at what a 1 mil is and
then we're going to take a look at two
examples from grandmaster games in which
the grandmasters were able to use this
tactic and completely destroy their
opponent so first let's go ahead and
take a look at what the windmill is it's
normally used with a bishop and a rook
against an exposed King as you can see
here this King is exposed there's not a
lot of protection around them so what we
can do we can bring our rook to b7 so
many times people if there's an exposed
King they always are looking for the
quick checkmate some fancy move a lot of
times it's these small moves like the
windmill that you can gobble up all your
opponent's pieces make the game a lot
easier for you instead of trying to get
that quick immediate checkmate a lot of
times you can gobble up all the pieces
and then the checkmate it's much more
easier so as you can see from here the
only move the black King can make is a 1
and now we can move our rook anywhere on
the board there's not anywhere that we
can go besides a7 and b7 where our rook
can be taken so as soon as we move our
rook the King is going to be in check so
we can pretty much move our work
anywhere and so we're going to take
advantage of that and we're going to
start taking all black's pieces away
from him because as soon as we move
first move is going to be rook to b4
capture b4
the king is in check and he's going to
have to move you can't move to b8
because of our rook so he's going to
have to move to a7 now we can repeat the
process bring our work back to b7 and
the whole reason we're bringing it back
here
and so that the key moves back to a8 and
then when we move our rook again he's
going to be in check as you can see
we're just going to repeat this process
he's gonna have to move to a7 we're
gonna come back check just so he comes
to a8 and we have another discovered
check from our bishop he continues to
have to move we bring our rook back to
b7 when he moves we can now bring our
work to b1 and now when he moves to a7
we can take his rook so as you can see
before we were down the material but
after the windmill were actually up now
a rook and a pawn and it's all because
the king is exposed we didn't even have
to move our bishop but every time we
moved our rook the king was in check and
he had to move his king or protect this
King there was no other way for him to
protect this King in this particular
situation then to move it and we could
just continuously with our rook come
back check and then take all his pieces
so this is how the windmill works now
let's go and take a look at two examples
in actual games where GM's were able to
use this tactic in their own games
the first example that we're going to
take a look at comes from a game played
by Repetto versus Lasker and if you want
to take a minute and see if you can
solve it on your own go ahead and pause
it but the first move is Bishop to f6
and this is a great move because blacks
King is under attack from our queen he's
going to have to take our Queen here on
h5 and once he does then as you can see
we have our rook and our bishop lined up
on this King and we're going to be able
to win a lot of material so we'll see
what that looks like here after the
Queen takes on h5 we can bring our rook
to g7 check again like before the king
is forced to come to h8 we can now take
on f7 he's forced to come back we can
just keep repeating check he moves to H
a discovered check we take on b7 his
King comes to g8 we come back to g7
after it comes to h8 an actual game the
RIP came down to g5 he'd want to take
this pawn so that the rook the rook
would come down and take this pawn on a2
he just decided that the pawn and the
bishop that he was taking would be
sufficient material but the king is
forced to move again he's now forced to
move to h7 because our rook is blocking
the G file and after he moved to page 7
then he was able to capture the Queen
get his Queen back we had to give up our
queen but we gained a pawn we gained two
pawns and we gained a bishop which for a
GM is sufficient material to easily win
a game so this is one example the next
example we're going to take a look
it comes from Bobby Fischer which many
of you have probably heard of and we'll
go ahead and take a look at that right
now
the great thing about this game is Bobby
Fischer was only 13 years when he played
in Bobby Fischer's using the black
pieces this first move is rook to e8
eyeing down this efile making sure that
the King can't do anything
setting up the windmill after the King
moves to f1 Bobby Fischer nicely placed
his bishop on e6 his queen is under
attack but he's actually going to
sacrifice that in exchange for this nice
little windmill that we'll see here
after Bishop takes on b6 then Bobby
Fischer brings his Bishop to c4 T you
can already see the tension why does not
castled so his rook on h1 is not doing
anything and Bobby Fischer is going to
use this king out in the center and use
a nice little windmill tactic with his
knight and his bishop along with his
rook eyeing down this Aoife to
completely mop up all the pieces that
white has from here the King can't move
to e1 so he moves to g1 and with Bobby
Fischer brings his Knight to e2 after
the king comes back to f1 Bobby Fischer
takes on d4 and after the king comes
back to g1 Bobby Fischer repeats
checking with Knight e 2 after the King
comes to f1 now Bobby Fischer brings his
Knight to c3 again discovered attack the
king is forced to move to g1 and now
Bobby Fischer captures on b6 captured
the bishop and at the same time attacks
this Queen on a3 the Queen is forced to
move II can't capture on a a because
Bobby Fischer's rook is here on EA and
after the Queen comes here
Bobby Fischer moved his rook to a four
then white captured on b6 trying to get
material but after Bobby Fischer took on
d1 Bobby Fischer went on to win a pretty
easy game the Queen has his White has
his Queen and his knight in the action
and black has two rooks two bishops and
a knight in the action this rook on h1
is never going to get into the action
and Bobby Fischer went on to win a
pretty easy game but you can see here
even using a knight and a bishop the
windmills can be pretty devastating even
if you do give up a queen many times the
material that you can get back in a game
more than compensates for that sacrifice
so always be looking out for if you have
a bishop a rook or bishop in the knight
eyeing down a king if you can use this
tactic because there's so many times in
a game that you can use this to your
advantage and take a huge advantage from
your opponent and capture a lot of his
pieces so hope you guys have enjoyed
this video on the windmill hope you guys
can see this in your own games and use
it well if you haven't already please
subscribe and if you haven't checked out
the website WWE Champion John I'll see
you guys next video thanks for watching